finalement alors je vous faire une
interview didon gamine mais c'est pas
moi qui vais vous poser des questions
ils ont une très bonne ou touche non la
moitié du carnet bon laval l'autre
moitié est moyenne ils ont nuit et je
lui ai dit vie retomber dhabi sur wii je
suis fier de mon père ben oui quand même
c'est un grand bonhomme amoureuse de lui
a jamais non ah non non non je n'ai
jamais recherché mon père dans les
hommes que j'ai connu pas du tout ah non
je n'aurais pas du tout voulu vivre avec
ni physiquement ni harnais ni moralement
ah non pas du tout mais je trouve que
c'est un grand bonhomme et je lui jeune
que moi c'était de devenir mécanicien de
locomotive
oui ça je le savais ça je le savais oui
parce qu'il voyait passer les trains à
l'arrêt de sa chambre quand il était
petit voilà ce extraordinaire qu en fait
la seule chose qui l'intéressé vraiment
c'était les chevaux et les trains quoi
electrabel l'acteur français la sncf a
peut-être perdu mais cinéma ya gagné
tout à fait on est bien d'accord
ils ont mieux une miche et le monde
ai-je qui est toujours logiques rouge
est toujours en à michel toujours et oui
bonucci coup il a jamais dit qu'elle
n'était qu'au delà la pauvreté face aux
enjeux excusez moi je gardais le moteur
alors
il abuse et la poubelle grandeur que
j'ai jamais vu un temps mêlé au moins
deux à penser la même chose
dix longues il est le petit de longs
skis tapez une un petit peu de tout mon
temps à ça ça je ne dirais pas donc ça
ça reste ma vie privée savoir un
prochain livre
a lille on lui est ce que c'est vraiment
j'étais chiant très chiant
t'aurais préféré de la ville leino ont
dû re ah j'aurais bien aimé que la fille
de l'ignorer ah oui c'était quelqu'un de
très très très bien quoi
quand vous êtes marié la première fois
contre l'avis de votre père lino est
venu au mariage
oui et c'est drôle parce que
effectivement maintenant que j'ai plus
mes parents quand j'ai un problème c'est
pas mon père que je pense je me dis
pourquoi est-ce que lino n'est pas là
parce que c'est lui qui met des très
très drôle plus que mon père dit domine
pas peur de me ressembler on lui change
au je pense que j'étais défaut est que
plus ça va aller plus je vais te
ressembler libre terim du harcouët qui
ont été l'un tous les genres dits chauds
oui mais y'a bon je me bouche à oreille
ben je te remercie de m'avoir donné ta
force mais malheureusement tu m'as donné
la fragilité
père braud candidat belga
c'est
en vue
je suis
essayez juste